what I like about you is you're very
unguarded when you when you talk you've
been talking to the press and you'll say
all kinds of stuff for work and you'll
go for it you'll go for joke you you've
caused a bit of a controversy creasing
Lee you're talking to the press and you
called Black Widow a [ __ ] yeah yeah
let's elaborate on that yeah yeah as a
joke off-colored or whatever but yeah
I'm an apology jack about a lot of
things and but yeah I gotten a lot of 12
internet trouble I guess that's a thing
now you can get in the Internet's a
brand new thing it's yeah and up on
America I was asked the questions like
so you know Blackwood has been linked to
Hawkeye Iron Man Bruce Banner and
Captain America so what do you think
about that I said but sounds like she's
a [ __ ] no mind you are talking about a
fictional character in fictional
behavior but gonna if you slept with
four of the six Avengers no matter how
much fun you had right you'd be a [ __ ]
yeah just saying obviously you just I'm
just curious which which one would she
be the most attracted to of all those
guys oh no man what thinking we're
talking about fictional characters and
it gets me maybe it's the whole she's
into the Hulk now yeah it's not
Quicksilver we know that things are over
with it's a quick evening with
Quicksilver yeah that's it that's what I
do